have you uh taken the test of five types
of love I have yes yes very good it's a
great test yeah it was so interesting to
see if we did it at uh family you know
yes my son's daughter-in-laws what are
yours I'm interested what are Your Love
Languages well um I'm
um acts of Love okay yeah I am not the
compliments yes yeah no words of
affirmation words
right right yeah don't give me the words
okay good to know and it's so
interesting because
um I S I see it all the time in our
relationship yes so being able to
articulate that yes I forgot what the
other ones are there's uh there's uh
words of affirmation
gifts touch and Time and Time quality
time yeah yeah quality time that's
important too but I see it when we did
the little test yeah and we did it we
could see where sometime it was going
like that yes yeah oh yeah completely it
can be totally opposite yeah in other
words I'm I'm giving you something yeah
and you're not appreciating it because
you're looking for the other type
exactly and it's so handy to do and
these personality profile tests are
valuable in finding out our nature yeah
and operating that way